- [Narrator] This April.
- This is my moment,
I've been training
since yesterday for this.
- [Host] Three, two, one.
(whistle blows)
- [Narrator] A game
show like no other.
- It wasn't easy, but you
know it wasn't hard either.
- Paint the best picture of a
horse whilst riding a horse.
- [Narrator] Pushing limits.
- Be gone, limits.
- I gotta win.
- Oh, come on.
- Where's the (bleep) ball?
- [Narrator] Testing
the human spirit.
- Will that be a open book test?
- Put as many blue M&M's in
the empty bowl as possible.
- [Host] Lisa, there's
one in your nose.
- [Narrator] And bringing
glory to one champion.
- Are there gonna be any snacks?
I get a bit lightheaded
when I don't eat.
- [Narrator] Five people enter.
- I didn't come here
to make friends.
(laughs)
That just happened by accident.
- [Narrator] All five leave.
- Do I wanna win, hell maybe.
- [Narrator] No
one is voted off.
- I'm 100% committed to
committing to this, I think.
- [Narrator] The stakes,
have never been lower.
- Hey voice over guy, how about
you tone it down a little bit.
- [Narrator] Taskmaster!
- That's me, I'm the taskmaster.
- And I'm the task assistant.
- That doesn't exist.
- [Narrator] New
series premieres,
Friday, April 27th at 11.
- Can you say bubbles for me?
- [Woman] No.
- Okay, thank you
so much though.